jeunes qui se sont fait vacciner pour
sortir aujourd'hui qui se disent je me
suis fait vacciner pour rien ils vont
fermer des discothèques pendant au moins
un mois c'est catastrophique en terme de
signal envoyé c'est catastrophique
quatre semaines qui penses tu qu'ils
trouvent que c'est une bonne idée crif
que ces dates c'est ridicule belle
c'était inéluctable événement assez des
lieux clos la nation flanc voyais
arriver c'est triste pour eux mais y
avait pas d'autre issue oui alors c'est
très bas lourd ce que je vais dire mais
à partir du moment où tu as toujours les
métros et les trains qui sont ouverts
ouais je vois pourquoi les discothèques
fermerait on sait très bien la galère
qui ont eu tous les patrons pendant deux
ans qui ont du mal à survivre à la
fermeture de leur établissement donc moi
je trouve ça très moyens voilà
et puis ça regarde comme ya des jours où
il ya deux ans qui a refermé ce qui a
fermé en premier c'était les
discothèques dont classe avec les
discothèques a pas ça être les
restaurants etc etc il arrive pas nous
dire tout va bien vous inquiétez pas
mais il ya des petites restrictions par
ci des petites restrictions par là je
trouve que en termes de signal ces
catastrophes ne dis pas que tout va bien
on nous dit qu'on est en plein dans
notre vie rapatriement il y aura pas de
couvre-feu mais ça recommence comme ya
deux ans voilà alors alors les annonces
alors ça y est on était fait merci
alexandre guerrier voilà donc donc ça y
est donc le premier ministre jean castex
voilà a tenu une conférence donc il n'y
aura pas de couvre-feu ni de confinement
c'est sur un sabir la couvre feu n'est
de confinement vers ça c'est certain
l'heure n'est pas des mesures de jauge
de couvre-feu de confinement ce serait
disproportionné a d'ailleurs annoncé
jean castex est une bonne nouvelle tant
de choses
oui alors pas de jauge attentes tu peux
remplir tes salomon michel tout va bien
voilà donc va donc y aura des meetings
politiques ça veut dire est ce que c'est
la question qu'on se posait encore hier
donc ils vont pouvoir continuer les
meetings politiques apparemment gilbert
mais je comprends pas le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas de jauge basse que la proximité
là c'est pas cohérent on ferme les
discothèques il faut que tout le monde
trinque un peu donc jauge dans les
salles de spectacles dans les
restaurants pour moi c'était
indispensable à je comprends pas
franchement maintenant les masques on
dénombre des masques débat au restaurant
n'avait pas de masque oui même s'il vous
plaît on avait masque mais vous avez vu
le meeting de zemmour ou les gens et
vous avez beau avoir les masques vous
avez vu comme un comme s'étaient
attroupés la plupart avaient le masque
en dessous enfin je veux dire abandonner
les masques faut pas non plus en
espérait tant de choses donc quand on
parle de discothèques soit pas pour le
voyez comme
le public ne bouge pas mais dans les
meetings les gens ils sont comme ça
alors sur les os les gens bougent
sont des gens qui bougent encore sachez
le comme les houles du romanche qui n'a
pas de sens c'est que pour les meetings
le passé les 20 dépôts obligatoires
oui ça c'est vrai ça n'a pas chassé en
matière d'onss interdite par la loire ce
qui est partant pour aller à l'église
c'est pas oublier non plus par contre si
un chanteur chante dans une église on
donne notre demande de passer à des
terres c'est sa c4 des choses qui sera
bientôt
pourquoi donner pourquoi pour les nos
téléspectateurs pourquoi dans les
meetings le pass sanitaire n'est pas
constitutionnelle c'est exactement voilà
on peut pas empêcher les gens de se
réunir pour exactement ce qui s'est
passé c'est pareil pour les syndicats
d'ailleurs voilà les lessives ou perd on
peut voir les des marchés de noël dans
toute la france les marchés de noël
quand vous êtes à l'extérieur du marché
donc à les stands qui donnent sur
l'extérieur donc là vous pouvez faire ce
que vous voulez et que si vous voulez
entrer dans le marché de noël ce qui est
exactement la même chose qu'à
l'extérieur parce qu'il ya autant de
gens à l'extérieur vous devez montrer
votre passe temps quand même d un
couffin des incohérences et ce bouquet
une fissure alors les autres mesures les
vaccinés la vaccination des 5 11 ans
atteint de comorbidité ouverte au 15
décembre donc les 5-11 ans pour les plus
fragiles avec des maladies voilà
exactement soit c'est normal voilà qui
présente ce qui présente des risques ça
c'est normal et donc je vous le dis
fermeture des boîtes de nuit pour quatre
semaines pour les quatre prochaines
semaines donc toutes les fêtes de fin
d'année le plus gros lot
voilà pour les patrons de discothèques
argentier ce texte a également demandé
aux français de lever le pied sur les
fiesta j'entends il vous c'est beau
c'est ce que je pense qu'il n'était que
pour vous en faites un je vous le dis le
vp sur les festins jusqu'aux fêtes de
fin d'année on lève le prix on se
protège des règles claires seront
édictées pour le monde professionnel les
fêtes de fin d'année sont elles menacées
selon vous a priori je vous dis ça va
être compliqué mais ça va être réduire
et restreint comme la dernière a ainsi
fermé oui c'est sûr que s'il n'y a pas
de mesures de contrainte coercitives là
je pense que c'est le dernier
avertissement est sinon ça va être
contrôleur encore plus strictes et c'est
donc moi de mon point de vue les fêtes
de noël elles seront pas normal il faut
alors être espacés il va falloir être
très vigilant et puis après il ya
l'effet boule de neige moi j'ai été
sidéré en savoie et haute savoie ce
week-end des gens qui appelaient pour
annuler one une soirée ya eu six appels
pour des annulations pour le réveillon
après meilhan away la hantise de la peur
la peur qui fait peur et c'est ils ont
vraiment là une vraie crainte de ça
alors on espère michel tu vas pouvoir
faire ton spectacle à tournai ouest dont
c'est bon tu vas pouvoir partir en
tournée et à paris je serai en à paris
en septembre ouais au petit marigny
battra dernière là où je inconnu mais en
ce moment c'est j'adore super pièces
superbes pièces sont coupables mais
voilà donc voilà les mesures du
gouvernement voilà je vous le dis est ce
que vous trouvez que cette bonne mesure
où à trop vous voulez la
gemmi mal et moi je me permets de poser
une question à quoi ça sert de se faire
vacciner si c'est pour qu'on referme
tout que tout tour ferme tour
à quoi à quoi sert le paraguay et à quoi
sert la vaccination cyril il ya plein de
gens qui se sont fait vacciner pour
voyager et pour sortir ils peuvent plus
voyager ils peuvent plus sortir donc ils
sont dégoûtés ils ont la sensation de
s'être fait arnaquer il ya plein de gens
qui ont fait le vaccin sous la
contrainte faut le complice et pourquoi
enfermer frontières non mais je dis moi
mais non mais non mais non mais moi ce
que je vois surtout c'est qu'on nous
impose on nous promet un retour à la vie
normale grâce à un vaccin qu'on nous
demande de faire trois fois pour le fait
trois fois et que rien ne change et
qu'on retourne comme il ya deux ans mais
c'est pardonne moi mais poser des
questions et de
la
pression d'être 12 mois en arrière
effectivement et les fêtes de la mer y
avait pas d y avait pas de vaccin et on
dit des bombes à eau - quand il y aura
un vaccin dans un an ça sera mieux voilà
en effet que si c'est pas mignon prends
ça mais malgré tout on pouvait pas
anticiper le barrio microbes on a
continué sur les dents des variants
savait très bien qu'il y en avoir il y
en aura encore et encore alors on va se
faire vacciner tous les ans comme la
grippe puis on ira glass airways limites
ils avaient tous les trois mois j'ai je
les ai une sorte d'impuissance vaccinale
je trouve fort que moi j'ai fait un
rappel là on commence à se dire alors
est-ce qui va pas falloir faire le
rappel du rappel est-ce qu'il est adapté
aux nouveaux variants les laboratoires
s'interroge je suis assez d'accord avec
guillaume quand même mais
c'est pareil dans belle épine
oui non mais je critique pas forcément
le gouvernement mais on nous dit
vaccinez vous et de fait c'est pas parce
qu'on est vacciné que tout va bien donc
ça lui plairait c'est ce que est ce que
l'invention que tout le monde ne sait
rien en fait
ça c'est vrai qu'il est venu en personne
tout le monde tâtonne parce que c'est
mon ego ça tâtonne depuis trois ans
maintenant donc enfin c'est bon c'est
vrai que ça commence les labos les
gouvernements les médecins eux mêmes qui
sont pas d'accord entre eux
il ya quand même un consensus sur le
fait que
le vaccin
valérie valérie arrêter behring
consensus ici cyril ça permet de ça
permet d'être arrêtés aux états unis
mais non mais non sans mal et tout ça
mais ce qu'il disait guillaume il a
envie de sortir il s'est fait vacciner
il dit que voilà les mecs qui sont fait
vacciner peuvent pas sortir non plus et
pour palomba denis
restaurant at on dit s'il vous plaît
les protocoles sanitaires n'ont pas
changé pour les restos les bars dessinée
ni les enfants pour l'instant oui pour
la baisse est déjà pas mal faire ça
commence quand même à regarder contre le
gouvernement vous inquiétez pas
c'est vrai un [ __ ] du gouvernement la
scène il est reparti mais que c'est un
coup d'arrêt qui est un peu des mots
rien sur la c1 route ou deux ans en
arrière on a essayé soit là mais bon ça
fait plaisir du canton de géraldine dire
ça pour une fois windows oui merci m
affaires faites ce que vous voulez la
guerre à tout en les mêlant merdes et
pas les autres